alright let's get started so functional
programming I'm a software developer
software engineer working at the company
called click that click I spend most of
my time working with c-sharp as the
primary programming language but I have
a background from functional languages
in particular I have some experience
with using Haskell and it's been very
interesting to learn c-sharp coming from
a Haskell background because I can
recognize a lot of those features that I
was used to using in Haskell also in
c-sharp they were lacking in languages
like C++ at the time when I joined but
there are been a lot of talks at this
conference I know about introduction to
functional programs know that this will
sort on that topic but what I'll be
doing is I'll be talking about two
specific features so c-sharp in
particular name with tuples and pattern
matching and I will show you how those
features have been used in in Haskell
because those have been part of Haskell
since the beginning which was 89 so it's
pretty older and they are very much a
native part of the toolkit you have when
you're when you're working with Haskell
and something special happens when you
take a feature and move it into a
language because you can use a certain
type of pattern based on those features
in a very different way than you can if
there are part of the part of the
language of the library or something
like that to put some pattern matching
were introduced in c-sharp seven two or
three years ago not remember exactly but
let's start I'll just give a brief
repetition hopefully of what these
features are so tuples everybody know
where to please hope so at least yeah so
basically synonymous datatype that
allows you to to group values of of any
type into a certain entity and just give
a small example here this is from the
standard maths library of c-sharp we
have the function div ramp which take
dividend and the divisor and it produces
what you get when you divide those
numbers as an integer and also produces
the reminder now this is conceptually a
function that returns two values right
and back in the days when C sharp
started there was no such thing as tuple
so the way you would do this if you want
to return two values was either to have
an out parameter like they did here
or you would have to have some sort of
structure that you were done which will
give some Allred and they chose this
part for them but using a tuple and
there's been a tuple library available
c-sharp for quite a while you could do
something like this you could instead of
having a out parameter we could return
an instance of this class a tuple which
contains two ins or we C sub seven you
can refer to it like this so we can just
use parent theses to construct a tuple
like this it's very nice convenient now
one thing is to define this and we will
define our a wrapper basically for this
dimmer different function by doing
something like this so we want to have a
div ram the returns a tuple of this type
what we'll do is basically we will call
our div I'm and wrap those two functions
or two values as as a tuple like this so
we can construct them very easily as
well without a lot of syntax for doing
that we just prep them in parantesis all
this is nice and a good syntactic sugar
but the interesting thing comes when you
want to consume these tuples because
that's where it's it differs so if I
want to say write a function that does
something like this it's supposed to
take a dividend and divisor and it's
goes to print the result of that
operation in a nice way so in this case
if you provide the values 3 and 13 and 5
then we should print 2 and 3/5 the way
we do this done is that we would call
our div ramp function which returns a
tuple we can immediately deconstruct the
value is coming from that function into
this tuple so instead of going we have
this extra name where we have to
associate names to the inner porch we
just get can deconstruct that and get
those names immediately now we can just
use them in our function like this and
also give a lot example how this is used
in haskell for all sorts of things not
just trivial things like this it has
some interesting consequences that you
might not think of because there's one
other thing when a feature comes into a
language you look at it say here yeah
that's nice syntactic sugar but
sometimes it's more to it because it
enables some patterns that you are not
used to
that's tuples second thing is pattern
matching pattern matching is little
harder to explain but I'll give a quick
example of this as well so imagine that
you have
function called compute area it's
actually taken from Microsoft's
description of pattern matching so we
get an object as an argument and we are
going to compute the area that object
based on what type address so if it's a
square with right B Square then we have
to type cost at shape to a square at
which point we get this handle now we
can access properties of the square
brace on the side so we can produce the
area here if it's a circle then we have
to typecast it to a circle and then we
can ask is the radius which of course
it's appropriate circle has but that the
square doesn't and so on and this is
also a so a pattern that you'll be using
for traversing data structures like this
where you need to know well you don't
know what the object type is but you
have to sort of do some some type
costing on this this is in case this is
necessary in cases where you can't have
this as a member function you can
imagine that the shape implements and
sort of object interface or something
but that's not always possible
especially with this shape comes from a
third-party library you can't just add
extra functions to it just out of the
box and then this type of pattern can be
very useful and in c-sharp 7 they
introduced pattern matching to capture
exactly this type of patterns so with C
shop 7 you can switch directly on this
object and then each case statements of
this switch statement will be pattern
matching on the type of that object so I
can now say if it's a square then I
immediately have a handle for a square
and I can access its side and return
that if it's a circle and I can access
the circle there as well and so on for
rectangles or whatever so there was a
quick repetitions of what these features
are about and I will be focusing this
talk on a certain domain in that I've
been working on from time to time which
is code generation code generation and
API testing so for some reason or other
I've been involved with a lot of
projects over the years where code
generation has been an important part of
what I've been doing
I've click where I'm working now one of
the first tasks I had when I joined the
company was to participate in a group
that were generating c-sharp code which
was supposed
be a layer on top of a JSON RPC protocol
so our tool provides as a computational
engine that you can communicate using
small text messages in code in JSON
which tells the engine what to do so
compute this for me or do this for me
and all that is handled using using JSON
which is syntactically very simple but
it's also very untyped it's tricky to
get those messages right from time to
time but in c-sharp of course if you
come as an c-sharp world you want to
have types on things that's why we great
the library that wraps all these JSON
RPC messages and allows us to produce
them using a type structure in c-sharp
so an example of a specification for one
of the methods we have in our product is
this one so this the name of the
function is called create object and it
takes two parameters or it takes one
parameters takes us properties for this
object and returns then one of these
objects and some other structure here
this is what the one of the parts of the
specification of that protocol looks
like for a product and we would take
this file consume it analyze it and
figure out ok we need a function called
create object and then we will use that
to generate c-sharp code that would
basically ensure that we produced in a
type safe way those jason structures
that we need to pass on over the over
the WebSockets to this tool so one of
the methods that we generate is this
this is a quite low-level method in in
what we generate but you can see that we
are picked up a lot of those parts of
this definition for instance we have
called we have a function here called
create object async this is an async
version of this method we also have a
synchronous version of it this name of
course comes directly from a
specification the input parameter is one
of these generic object properties this
itself is data structure that is also
defined as part of this protocol so we
will be generating a lot of cost
structures that that encapsulate this
and what this function does is that it
creates this request objects and here we
are starting to build the actual JSON
part because this will go directly into
the method name that we are sending over
the WebSockets so here we are starting
brios drinks now has anyone here done
any cogeneration anytime some of you
yeah
so first approach to doing cogeneration
is that if you haven't done it before
it's sort of the first thing you will
say is that he is just about
concatenating strings and to some level
that is correct but if you are to
produce something more complex then that
starts quickly to become very difficult
to scale because if you're just
concatenate extremes and doing all of
these operations then you very quickly
end up in places where you have or mr.
Perron theis is there or you know
there's a syntax error on this function
there and that that debugging process
and turnaround time for that can be very
very tricky so when we do this project
we were using a different technology a
technology called Cottam which is a
library from Microsoft senemo News code
on yeah some the code room is basically
a library that allows you to build the
structures of a program without
considering its syntax an example of
what that would look like is if I want
to build this expression X plus 1 minus
1 then in code um that would be
expressed like this so we create an
object which is a binary operator
expression this takes 3 arguments it
takes a left value it takes an operator
and takes a right value the left value
in this case is the variable X so then
we have a code variable reference
expression and the right value that's
another binary operator which contains
primitive expression 1 and the operator
subtract so what's the other wants to do
this well the result of using a library
like this is that you build basically
what is called an abstract syntax tree
instead of building the syntax directly
you are building the structure of the
program that you're going to generate so
we end up with a tree like this where we
have the binary operators we have all
the Leafs now we can take this tree and
now we can generate the code for that
for the language you want and at this
point there is two ways to do this or
they might more but two there I've got
to talk about here a first one is the
object oriented approach
the object-oriented approach would be to
leave the responsibility of doing the
printing to the individual notes so we
will have all these nodes implement an
interface or being a extension of some
abstract abstract class and then we
could have virtual functions saying that
okay a binary operator needs to
implement the print did self function it
knows he needs to print the subtrees and
so on but there's a problem to that
which I mentioned earlier as well it's
not always possible to do that because
if this objects all this objects come
from are from a third-party vendor then
it's you can't just add functions like
that on the fly me at least virtual
method counts be added like that easily
let's community role tricky and there's
no disadvantage to that and that is that
if I want to print this tree four
different languages I mean this tree
here this structure of the program this
is really language agnostic this is the
same thing for a c-sharp s4 go or a C++
read in Haskell the structure of the
program is the same and if I want to
take this structure and print both the
Java and c-sharp then I will need to
have different functions for those
different languages and another way to
go about doing that is to not leave that
responsibility to into the individual
nodes but instead leave that
responsibility to a function a function
that traverses the tree and prints it
according to whatever rules you want you
would like so you could have one
function for printing c-sharp one for
printing Java one fussy for C++ and so
on let me the functional approach you
you are disentangling responsibility of
what to do with the data structure from
the data structure itself you separate
this to those two now now I'm gonna
switch the Haskell how everybody here
done any Haskell anytime anybody knows
it quite a few you good all right so
I'll I'll go isn't you and if you have
any questions of course you should stop
me but I'll show you how to express this
type of structures in Haskell so first
of all in Haskell you have a type of tie
closer types that is sort of different
from what you see in c-sharp and most of
these languages which is what it's
called an algebraic data type is a fancy
name for it but it's basically a data
type that comes in multiple different
flavors so we can define a data type
that corresponds to an expression and
this data type will have three different
flavors so you can be either on number
which point it has an interest an
argument or it contains an int or it can
be a variable which will contain a
string X in this example or it can be a
binary operator and the binary operator
must have an operator and it will have
two sub expressions this is a recursive
data type which you which you use to
build this type of trees right the
operator I will just say is a numerable
basically so we can have four different
values at the sub motive so this allows
us to build a relatively simple set of
operations like this so if we now want
to produce this expression the X plus
one minus one it has to be repeated like
this so these data structures
immediately translate into constructor
functions that allows us to produce
instances of this type so the binary
operator is a top-level node it's an ad
and the left expression is the variable
X and the right expression is the binary
operator where we subtract one from one
it's very easy to define these types
that's comparing that to the code um
syntax that's very verbose compared to
this it this is absolutely a subset of
what we can do in encode um of course
but still there's a very big difference
in how verbose these languages are when
it comes to doing things like this all
right so now we have a way to express
this type of tree but of course we want
to do something with them you want to
apply functions to them so now we're
going to write a function print expert
that takes one of these expressions and
turns it into a string and at this point
we use pattern matching we have to use
pattern matching to do stuff on this
type of of algebraic data types and we
use it all the time in high school for
doing things like this because this
a table comes in three different flavors
so we will basically pattern-matching on
those three flavors and depending on
which flavor we are looking at we will
do different things so if it's a number
now we'll just do a case which in this
if it's a number then we just turn that
number into string show is the function
in Haskell for taking a value and
turning industry if it's variable well
then we have the idea of that variable
it is already a strings we can just
print that out if the binary operator
that is typically the interesting case
in in situations like this then we will
have to print the left expression we
will have to print the right expression
we have to print the operator and then
we wrap it all in a parenthesis and this
gives us a list of lists and we can use
concatenate which is a function Haskell
which takes a list of lists and
concatenate them into one so string in
Haskell is presented as a list of
characters that's also a string this is
a list of Lists basically that allows us
to print these trees all right let's do
another one a little more interesting
one so we can all see from this little
tree here that there is rooms to
optimize that tree we have one minus one
as one of the nodes we know that can be
turned into zero one minus one is zero
so let's write a small function that
takes one of these trees and tries to
simplify it we call it simplify and it
takes an expression as an argument and
returns another possibly simplified
expression so how do we do that all
right we will be switching on pattern
matching on the on the expression and if
it's a leaf if it's a number or variable
well then we can't simplify it any more
so we just return the original
expression underscore here is a don't
care term it means that we don't care
what those values are that are contained
in it also very convenient I think that
was introduced in c-sharp recently as
well it's very nice way to just say that
I'm not interested in this don't worry
about it so if it says leaf then we just
return it if the binary operator what
should we do
any suggestions what do we do in the
case of a binary operator
we run it exactly at this point we are
actually potential to do simplification
but in order to simplify it we first has
to see how to simplify the subtrees
because they could yourself be collapsed
to something some node so we're going to
simplify those two trees and then we're
going to do some operations on it and
the way we simplify those two trees is
like this using a tuple so we construct
here a tuple where the two values of the
tuple or the simplified version of the
left tree and the simplified version or
the right tree and why do we do that
well to be able to do pattern matching
on it can now we can deck directly
pattern match on that tuple with its
inner values and if both of those sub
trees simplify to a number then we can
actually do the evaluation we want this
is the function need to define which
takes an operator on those two intz and
actually does the miners here and if
it's not if they are not both numbers
well then we have to possibly simplify
expressions we just returned by the
operator again this is the way you would
typically use tuples and patta meshed
together in haskell to just create these
short-lived instances of these types in
order to do whatever you want it's a
very convenient way of handling these
type of operations all right that's the
first introduction to haskell pattern
matching and tuples before I continue
now with the main part I will have to go
a little into the type system of ASCO
and in particular I'm going to talk
about generic types so imagine that you
want to write a function that we would
call map it takes an a function as an
argument so a function that turns on int
into another int and it takes a list of
integers and it applies this function to
all of those hints this is what you this
is called select in c-sharp right okay
so we define that is that we pattern
match so the base case would be when we
have an empty list if you have an empty
list well let me return them to list not
much more to do there it is not an empty
list and then again we pattern match on
a non empty list
deconstructing it
this when we apply our function to the
first value and put that in front of
what we get when you apply when we do
map with this function on the rest of
the list so it's a recursive way to
define this nasco now this function
doesn't ever use any aspects of the type
it operates on the only thing that is
really interesting to is is that the
function the type of the function
matches the type of the elements of the
list so we don't really need to do this
for only integrals we can do this for a
generic type and the way you will define
that in Haskell is using a type variable
so in the standard functions you get
with Haskell you have this generic type
for map that looks like this and the way
you would distinguish between type
variables and type names is that type
variables have lower case letter and
start the local setter and type name
start with a capital letter so this is
the type signature from map it takes a
function with this as type from A to B
takes a as inputs and returns B and a
list of values of that type a and
returns a list of ice would type B and
the definition of the function will be
exactly identical to what we had earlier
this is how you define generic types in
in Haskell to do polymorphism and
applies never so now we can for instance
apply this to never comprise the n type
you have there should be a little more
complex example which is LM LM is also a
function in Haskell that takes a value
as argument and a list of values and
returns true if that list contains that
value right the way we define this again
in pattern matching so on the empty list
its false
that doesn't contain this value if it's
non-empty then either the element is
equal to the first elemental list or
it's an element to the rest of the list
so we have a recursion here as well a he
writes little problem because at this
point we are actually using some
behavior that we expect that function
that type to have we can see what that
is
equality exactly we can only do this if
a supports equality
not all types do that functions for
instance if you want to check if a
function is member of another list of
functions and I can't do that because
there's no good way of comparing
functions so in this case we need a
constraint we can't define this for all
times we can only define this for those
types that support equality and the way
they solve that in Haskell is using a
concept called a type clause so type
class the most the cost thing you get in
c-sharp an object-oriented language is
an interface basically a type laws
define a set of functions function
signatures and any type that claims to
be a member of this class needs to
implement these functions and the
Equality class will contain definition
for equality and inequality and if a
function if a cross defines that then
you can actually use them with you use
them for comparison so our LM function
always to do to make this compile
because this doesn't compile in Haskell
is to add a qualification on a type we
need to say that a has to be a member of
the Equality class and if it is then
this is fine because then we can use
equality and now we can do for instance
LM 3 on 1 2 3 or we can do LM I on this
is my list and we can do comparison or
all kinds of different type another type
class that is common Haskell is the enum
sauce so enum is the class used for
doing enumeration so allows you to count
different stuff and it contains a number
of function but the two most important
or the successor and pre the best as a
function which is all the fundamentals
of doing enumeration you want to count
them and with this function we can for
instance apply map map suck the
successor function on integers we can
get like this remember that the map
function can take any values we doesn't
care about what what types it is but in
order for this to work we know that or
the integer type must support this
function which is for this class which
means that you can only apply this to
two lists all of the numerals but of
course in this enumerable we can do that
there clearly or begin apply the strings
so we can
say four it's a map suck on Howell and
get our IBM right and then we recognize
that no look at all Pater interesting
thing anyway
let's go back to our little type tiles
here so we had the expression data type
and we have the simplify function and
what I'm going to talk about as I
mentioned earlier is test case
generation randomized test cases and we
are going to use now a very interesting
library in Haskell called quick check
and what Crick fares is all about is to
generate random test cases for you based
on a certain type and then try to figure
out find bugs in your programs based on
those random test cases one of the
things quick check introduces is a new
type cause the type clause it calls
arbitrary so any type that claims to be
a member of this class needs to
implement a function called arbitrary
and that is basically a function that
states how you would generate a random
instance of this type so we'll now go
ahead and make our expression Clause an
instance of this type to do that we say
just instance arbitrary expert where now
we have to implement those part of those
functions that are included in the class
definition so we need to implement this
arbitrary function here and our
expression class as you know comes in
three different flavors numbers
variables and binary operators so our
job will basically be to write one
generator for each of those flavors and
then use this function coming from
quickcheck which takes three generators
and just randomly picks one so we'll
start by writing a generator for the
number flavor and the way we do that is
like this so we say we produce an
arbitrary int and then we'll return that
and wrap it with the num constructor
there's an interesting thing to say
about this and that is that I never in
this code explicitly say here that the
end produced by the arbitrary is an
integer and this is a consequence of a
very surface
type inference technique that is used in
Haskell that allows you to eliminate a
lot of those type information from your
code directly because it can just you
know the only type and can have as int
because I use the num constructor on it
and that requires named since num is
used an n n has to be an int and his n
incident this arbitrary function here
must be the arbitrary function that
generates an int it can't be the
function that generates a random
character or a random expression it must
be named
so next step to generate a random
variable we will just do something very
simple I will just say that I will pick
one of these two big values so elements
takes a list of values and just randomly
picks one them so the variables we would
call X wire set obviously in a real
world environment you would probably do
something more advanced here and find in
the binary operator what about that
that's the interesting part well we have
to generate a random operator you have
to generate a random left expression and
you have to generate a random right
expression now they have those we can
just wrap them in that binary operator
constructor and again I'm just writing
here arbitrary arbitrary arbitrary I
don't have to say anything explicitly
about those types because those are all
forced on the on the language by where
I'm using them the binary objects pets
expects a random expects a an operator
into expressions that means that these
arbitrary expressions has to generate
those values when here comes an
interesting part as well since tuples is
a native part of Haskell libraries like
quick check with a function for
generated tuples as well so I can reduce
this instead of writing arbitrary three
times I can just say give me a random
tuple and now that I'm used in the
deconstruction here immediately the type
system will know that this arbitrary
function must be the arbitrary function
generates our three tuple and the inner
types of that tuple is forced upon it
based on menu where I'm using it here
it's very nice way to write things I
think I'll just show you quickly how to
write this
this instance of the arbitrary on a pair
of values so a tuple with two values
first of all we need to have a
constraint there as well because we can
only generate a tuple if the types that
that is contained by that tuple are also
instance of this arbitrary choice you
have to be able to generate arbitrary
versions over so we have to add this
qualifier arbitrary a an arbitrary B is
both of those are arbitrary then even
arbitrary of the pair of those values is
arbitrary and the way we define
arbitrary here is just you produce an X
we produce in Y and we return the pair
it's very simple to do and if we want to
do this for a three tuple that's almost
the same thing we need to just say that
this third value also is in our instance
of the arbitrary clause and when we do
we can just add the first value so
generate the first value now that you
have a definition on how to generate a
tuple well we can just generate a tuple
here appear and then return that three
tuple like this let's see in the in the
quick check code that they have all
these different sections where you later
generate up to I think it's like 13
values of something there's some in in
the standard it says how many have
larger these tuples library is supposed
to be able to generate but you you
rarely use that large tuples anyway
because if you have that type of big
data structures you usually start
wrapping it in something that is more
concise and something that more explains
what you're doing but these type of
functions are used all the time so let's
go back to this expression of us here is
the entire code required to generate an
arbitrary expression and I also added an
instance arbitrary instance for for the
operator itself and what I do then is I
just randomly pick one of those for in
some cases you will have restrictions on
what type or what subset of a certain
type you you will you will need in a in
a code so if I for instance want to be
able to generate a tree that contains
only positive or non-negative values in
the different nodes then I can't just
use the arbitrary here
directly on the ends and the way you
would typically do that control that so
in in Haskell is that it would sort of
wrap the behavior that you want for a
certain type that you want to generate
in a specific type so if I want this
tree to only contain non-negative values
then I would introduce a new type just a
wrapper for int I'll define this part
this type and as an instance of the
object class and define what I want to
do there so a natural number should only
contain zero or larger numbers the way I
will do that I will just generate random
value I will wrap it use in there with a
natural construct and do the absolute
value on that that way I can guarantee
that when I produce values for this type
I will only get positive values and now
that I have this all I need to do to
make sure that this code produces trees
with only positive values in it is to
add the constructor here because by
deconstructing my data type like this
I'm suddenly forcing this arbitrary
function to generate natural values not
just int this is very convenient thing
to have another place where it's used a
lot is for generating lists so often if
you have list as an argument there will
be constraints on what types of lists
you can have in it might phrases be that
you don't accept empty lists as an
argument in that case I can produce a
type which say is a non empty this is a
basica wrapper for non-empty lists
non-empty ticket has a type a type a is
basically generated like this if a is an
or is the arbitrary type then I can just
generate a random list if the list is
empty knowledge the function used in
Haskell to determine if the list is
empty if it's empty
well I just generate again if it is not
empty then I have a non-empty list I can
return it you see a lot of these
patterns and in the quick check library
you'll find instances for instance of
sorted lists or lists containing unique
values and all of these kinds of things
a lot of them
permutations of different values and all
that all right so let's return to our
little data structure here and the prop
and the function we wrote on it we wrote
this simplify function to take a tree
and and and simplify it and now we're
going to use this for testing and since
we have a way to generate random
instances of this expression we also
need a way to test those random values
and one of the problems with random test
cases that you don't really know what
they're supposed to do that's what we do
we do unit testing and some of you have
a very clear picture where we want to
end up for random test cases we don't so
in order to test them we have to use
property based testing we have to define
some sort of a behavior that we know
these this data type or these functions
should always exhibit and the behavior
in this case that I will use for
demonstration purposes is the fact that
when you simplify a tree the size of the
resulting tree will always in terms of
number of nodes must always be smaller
than or equal to the original tree very
trivial example trivial property but to
do that we need a little help fraction
we need a function for computing the
size of a tree this should be easier now
that you are expert in pattern matching
and tuples how do we do this Casey so
justice you for the Leafs the size of
Leafs is just 1 so numbers of variables
is just one node large binary operators
how large are they yes some exactly 1
plus the sum of the size of the two sub
trees and now that they have this small
function we can write our property now
we'll call that property prop
simplification reduces size this is sort
of a the way you would typically name
your properties in highschool and this
property is basically predicate it takes
an instance of our expression type and
returns a boolean
so if that simplification works
correctly then this should always return
true and the way we define this that
when we take an expression as argument E
and we just compute the size of e and
then we compare that to the size of what
to get to in the simplify and this
should return to for all possible
instances of this expression class all
right
yes that's true so we didn't say so this
is only a property of expect from it but
it's not the full set of qualities that
we like to simplify property to have
it's just one of them
absolutely so if you're working on using
a property based testing larger sense
you will try to capture more behavior of
this mystery than what you want there
but this is just one of them I'll use
for something all right let's run that
so here we have no you can see it
all right so this will actually run
random generation on all its care to do
it in a presentation that hope it works
there we go and we have a failing test
case you can all see what the problem is
right that is the other problem with
random task energized case generation
the test cases Europe end up with are
usually very very confusing big test
cases containing a lot of noise that are
actually relevant to the actual problem
but this is a real bug in the code we
just wrote I assure you and this is
where I think quick check really shines
because what happens when you get this
type of failure is that you can do more
than just look at that initial initial
test case you get because quick check
includes another function this arbitrary
class includes not a function call
shrink the shrink takes a value of this
type and it's supposed to produce a list
of smaller versions of that same value
and the idea here would be that once we
have found a test case failure we can
produce all these smaller versions and
we can try the properties news and if we
are unable to lim eliminate any
information from that original test case
and still get a failing property then we
have reduced the size of that failure or
the example we have and something that
is a hope that hopefully more easy to
read and then we can do it over again so
we can try to shrink that one and you
can do this over and over again until we
reach a stable minimum where we're not
able to shrink anymore so how would we
define the shrink function for our
expression clause well we have already
have the arbitrary toss
we will Pat a match on the flavors so if
it's a number then we call the built-in
shrink function for integers which is
just shrink and then we map this number
construct to it so this gives the list
or different numbers that are smaller
than the original number
and four variables well you could you
could do stuff here as well and
depending on your implementation and
your environment this could be
differently complex but I will just say
that it's not possible to shrink a
variable so I will just return the empty
list there no way to shrink it and if
it's a binary operator what do we do
then you suggestions on how to shrink a
binary operator with that you can shrink
the subtrees absolutely or you could
just drop the binary operator all
together and just try the subtrees it
might be that this binary opera is
actually not necessary for the property
to fill so we can just drop it and see
what happens so those are two possible
ways to shrink a binary operator just
take the subtrees and if that's not good
enough
then we have to shrink this shrink the
kids so we can shrink the operator and
we could discuss what you would mean by
shrinking the operator here but you can
define the versions for that for
instance you all just go to the left and
try to see if you can reduce to add or
we can shrink the left operator or we
can shrink the right operator
all right sub-tree I mean and this in
the end we end up with a huge list of
different possible ways to shrink the of
the the binary operator and when we are
running quick check now we can just
start reversing them so you can scan
through them see if you can find a
failure if you do you have a smaller
case and we can run again let's do this
so we stopped drinking here we found a
smaller version of it and see what it
removed it remove this binary operator
returns the left-hand side of that
operator we can continue shrinking it
become smaller and smaller this was a
big one
and now we see is reducing it to
something that is much more
comprehensible and finally starting to
do reducing the inner numbers now we end
up with that and now it's pretty clear
what happened right you can see what the
problem is
any one divided by zero yes we didn't
take care of the case where we would
have this expression return a values
that will simplify to zero because then
get divided by series
this is actually an exception being
thrown when you run this this property
and having this shrink operations done
on your test cases is very very valuable
because what you end up with is
typically a very very small test case
where every single part of that case the
test case is necessary for the property
to fill because all the other things
have been been removed by this shrink
operation so it's very often the case
when you get one of these examples you
can look at it say oh yeah of course I
didn't think about that
then you will fix your book and you run
again and continue doing this testing
like this
so I'll talk a little about one
real-world use case where I use this
technique and this was for API testing
so this was this was not a click it was
a previous company where we were
producing we were writing a building a
tool that had a command-line interface
for it which is so we could write
scripts for working with this tool and
we were having some issues with with
quality so at one point I started
experimenting using a quick check for
doing that typo testing and what I did
was this I wrote a program that would
generate a random script based on an
abstract syntax pretty much like what I
had now but a little more complex than
that of course it will generate random
scripts encapsulating the different
commands that is tools supported then I
will just run those scripts in the tool
and the property would be very basic I
would be looking for crashes no pointer
exceptions when this was tremendously
useful we found hundreds of box of this
and most of them almost everyone all of
those test cases were three or four
lines of code long containing exactly
the command sequence necessary to get to
the point with the tool crash there was
some a few notable exceptions one of
them was a case test case where I think
it was 32 lines what happened was that
we had this feature that you can turn on
and off and apparently if you did that
more than 32 times within one second
then you have a buffer overflow and the
tool would hang which was pretty curious
because I spent way too many hours
looking at the toll shrinking these
scripts because the interest is easy
where I ended up like I see that what on
earth is doing because he's picking out
all these small subsections and I ended
up with this sequence where it on off on
off on off Lang very very useful and I
can say that within the functional
community this type of testing is used
quite a lot its I haven't seen it much
in in the object-oriented well
unfortunately because I think we are
really missing out on something here and
there are other parts of the industry
but this is a very prolific way of doing
testing and for instance you will see
that the Erlang
for instance at Eric's on the corner
they are using this type of testing a
lot and if you're curious to learn more
about that there's a very good talk by
John Hughes one of the inventors of
quick check talked about some of the
interesting cases they found that on
some database tests using quick check
it's really interesting to see how how
they were able to produce some very
nasty bugs and find some very nice bags
using this technique also in the
hardware industry if you're developing a
chip for instance when Ericsson is
developing it their base station chips
then they're using randomized test
generation all over the place that is
the main way of doing testing of
microchips and one of the reasons there
is that the cost of fixing a bug once
it's in silicon in hardware is so
tremendously high that they have to
ensure that they get as many of those
bugs out of the way before they actually
produce it and they're randomized test
generation is it's really a staple food
for for the testers that's what they do
the build is big test benches and have
this running these randomized tests over
and over again you can run for four
weeks to find this all right just a
quick summary at the end there so
c-sharp 7 introduces some features
mainly tuples and pattern matching that
has been around in the functional world
for quite a long time and my hypothesis
and i hope you agree with me is that
introducing those features as native
part of the language opens up the
possibility of doing stuff you probably
wouldn't have done otherwise because
they are too verbose or just too awkward
to do without those patterns and I think
that having pattern matching and tuples
available in in c-sharp in the native
way is something that will benefit a lot
from in the coming years and it's
something that hopefully will be
prolific and a natural part of your
toolkit when you're doing development in
those languages and just as lambda
expressions the link introduced the
constant stream processing which is now
very ubiquitous in the c-sharp community
I think these tuples and pattern
matching will allow us to do this type
of functional processes and data
structures
we are used to in the and Haskell
community all right just a few quick
references if you want to have a look at
the demo it's available in my github
account so you can experiment with there
if you like and have a look at there are
some demo cheats in there so don't be
too hard on me if you actually look at
it if you want to look at a quick check
examples they are also available I think
this was from actually NDC number of
years ago and finally I did a similar
presentation I can't stop stream based
processing using the link in c-sharp
which might find interesting if you
enjoy this alright thank you very much
any questions at the end yes
so the question is how you would apply
this in c-sharp
well the visitor patterning is nice but
you country as I said there are cases
for you country to do that because you
are have you have this third-party
library that you can't extend on I think
the example that Microsoft used Sun on
his on their website is some of these
graphical elements from one of the
libraries if you want to do functions on
top of those it's not that easy to do
that yeah okay perhaps I misunderstood
you I have to
okay but in the Vista pattern you
basically have to do pattern national
right yeah so you have the pattern
matching the rest of them
yeah that's that's what the switch
statement is for it
yeah but within that visitor pattern you
will basically be doing this pattern
matching because that will have to
implement four different different types
you will have to do the pattern instead
but okay but at some point you will
actually have to do that button mashing
or you'll have to write different
functions for different elements for for
for the different types right but I
agree
you're probably right that you are vista
parties doing something similar to this
it is separating the functions you want
to do on those types from the data type
itself absolutely so in that case the in
that type there there is a lot of
overlap for them but this is this type
of pattern matching is is built
specifically to allow you to do that in
the communion rail and in fact a good
point on that is that many of these
features that come into the language or
really encapsulations of all the design
patterns that would be used for quite a
while so the visitor pattern might be
similar to this but I mean there's other
features of the language that we are
very used to doing that are now native
the language like inheritance
object-oriented himself people were
doing object-oriented development in the
sea long before C++ came around with
object-oriented values or Batory of the
features but now that they are in the
future in the language you were just so
used them you don't really think of them
as patterns anymore any other questions
if there's an implementation a quick
check for c-sharp yes there is a least a
basic version of it I never tried it
myself but I think we are some way from
making this very convenient thing to do
in use in c-sharp but there are ways of
doing this type of generation for
c-sharp but I think that as I shown you
in this talk there are still features in
high school that are not present in
c-sharp yeah that makes a quick check
very convenient in c-sharp in Haskell I
mean but I hope that we will see this
type of patterns being used there more
and hopefully I will get to a point
where we can do things like quick check
in a community where you're sincere any
other questions okay
thank you very much
[Applause]